206 motion detected sweet to hear the
break-in enough is enough ha ha looks
like that crime wave just wiped out Tim
what have you done I just caught the guy
that's been breaking into our office um
that's Ian stalker he's one of the
Indian mega jam guys it's been winning
our space uh okay wait what and his
artist Randy hey I didn't kill that guy
hey I'm trying to sleep here oh my god
who killed Ian oh man Jess and I were
just talking about how we want to help
other Indies specifically not killing
them well uh just get help get the word
out right I'll handle this poor ian we
had just finished the sequel to his
amazing game escape goat escape wha
with what was it a mouse now the world
will never know you're wrong the world
will know about this game Double Fine
will help promote it and even though is
dead the world will always remember
what's his name yeah my name is Ian and
I'm not dead they'll think of him every
time they play Tim Schafer's escape goat
to you say hey guys have a lie it's it's
okay he's not dead he could sue we're
not calling it that Jim schaeffer's go
to scape to wipe don't fun with Papa T
this is my game compromise will name it
after you but you change your name is
tim schafer no way I'm just trying to
help get the word out about a scapegoat
20 like Oprah's Book Club Oprah didn't
rename it to oprah winfrey's Eat Pray
Love oh so now the scapegoat two is
better than eat pray love hi right what
what I mean you think a scapegoat two is
better than the road well the arts
better and it's got a goat in it Justin
bucket oh hang on what if we make one of
your dumb little videos um can I have
most lines is there a way to stop you
it's deal let's do this
dude how about that no yeah fine
I made this now he didn't